all right well listen we're rolling
ladies and gentlemen officially the
bootleg cab podcast special guest in
here yeah my guy a.d my guy adam 22
always dancing
what a.d oh
all right hey i want to thank you for
taking him out of the club thank you
thank you for pointing that out nobody
ever gives me [ __ ] you i got him off
alcohol
i got him in a healthy relationship i
got him in the podcast studio he's not
in compton anymore thank you kev
man this guy
right here would be at i don't know how
i could go to three clubs in a night and
this [ __ ] would be at every
single one with a section i'm like bro
what
you got clones or some [ __ ] i still
haven't made it to one with him i'll be
in san diego he's in the club i'll be in
scottsdale he's in the club the show i'm
already boy
what the [ __ ] a.d hey man just in that
juice bag for
how many years
hey come through perform juice man i got
a few grand for you bro hey bro
i would always see you in like random
places bro
like basketball charity games and [ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] kev is here
best buy parking lot chad's heart guy we
won't mention his name
shout out to our best buy guy
oh of course yeah yeah yeah yeah hey
appreciate that
homie's been looking out hey we made a
run this week
i mean it was christmas man best buy guy
he was just telling me he got a designer
guy we got a designer guy too
i'm not interested in designer shout out
designer
shout out to designer you know the best
buy guy designer obviously always comes
in office was the worst kanye
[Music]
like three years ago no he came to my
house no i did but did that never come
out it never came out
also you was a fake one no what happened
was noriega i announced i was gonna drop
the [ __ ] and nori called me and was like
yo don't do nothing i'm doing the drink
drink champs networking i want you to be
the first podcast
and
we talked bro we like went we met about
it like five times and he was like had
some sort of negotiations going on it
just never ended up where i was just
deflated about the whole thing and
then the pen by then the album the the
interview was old yeah it was like super
old and then like i recorded a few
but um i can't believe i didn't notice
that it didn't come out i feel like i
would normally was he bald
sick and yeah
bald yeah for sure bald yeah that's hard
it was in my basement wow i went there i
remember like walking in and just seeing
like
18 [ __ ] pairs of little kids shoes
in the the entry and i'm like oh this
[ __ ] got killed so is he is it
the kid or is he like [ __ ] with a
little person no it's cool i got two
kids as far as i know i'm making sure
you know what i'm saying kev's a crazy
guy most guys i know have at least a
couple midgets living in their basement
that's what i'm saying yeah
that's awesome
just to know those kind of people right
i mean hey
yeah
i mean did you just i feel like did you
just have a tiny person on
have you done like a tiny person porno
podcast yet
no
i had a town on
yo a-town i had i talked to him in tampa
like in 2014 and it was very i felt he
it was when he was rolling with the big
guy who was taking advantage of him
oh man
and like it was very obvious that that
dude was like
really in that kid's pockets what was
that big dude's name snacks snacks
yeah and i was like this is super weird
like well picture this for me have you
seen the show 60 days in the prison show
oh it's amazing prison show where they
put all these hidden cameras in the in
the prison and everything and it's so
good and there's netflix uh yeah that's
where i saw it and uh there's this one
guy abner who's like the king of the
chicanos and he like i think he used to
be a latin king and like you know did
all those crazy [ __ ] shot people etc
went in did time got out and then he
ended up being like basically one of the
contestants on the show where you go
undercover as a
civilian in this prison and you
basically live for like a couple months
as a prisoner and so i i look at my
calendar and i realize like oh my
interview is not just with this dude
abner it's with abner and a-town and i'm
thinking oh a-town's gotta be like
another prisoner
from the show of course because that
sounds like like yeah someone's street
name and then i hop on youtube and i
start searching it up and i'm like it's
a random wait a minute this is the
bird guys this guy
you know he was tight he's a cool guy
he's anti-bullying yeah that's this
whole thing bro you know he can speak
like full mandarin bro
the bird i swear bro he's smart as [ __ ]
how did he learn why would he be feeling
bad for some of these uh kids like you
know you always see that one the gotham
kid on like hollywood boulevard just
looking like oh well yeah
that's [ __ ] up man it's him in vegas
and stuff yeah you know it's vegas he's
like a.d be getting them people laid
though he'd be like oh you had to bring
this up man
you got wealth in the great lakes no i
got i got 18 on some ass before man you
know what i'm saying i had to look out
for the homie man
i'm just hey i'm keeping it i'm saying
he told me that i'm like
i just want to know like what's the girl
who's like she was a nice looking woman
yeah but like what what's her story like
why would she like like
yeah i [ __ ] a town i mean she i mean we
was chilling are you in a town eskimo
brothers definitely yeah we are wow wow
you don't think we don't revisit that
after eight town was there though right
no no no you just leave that i did it
first and then they were just like what
i'm saying and she was just basically
like hey like i you know
i like i like to [ __ ] and i do anything
you tell me to do and he came in i was
like the homie popping she was just like
i want to [ __ ] him i told heyton i was
like you know who was getting um who was
getting [ __ ] too was that little skinny
uh long neck [ __ ] too
man the other day a girl told me that
she sucked his dick
i'm like that's hard
shout out to you for taking care of him
that's crazy that should let you know
clout
is big it oversees everything you know
it's bigger than everything they'll do
it nah for sure that's crazy now we were
just talking about i've been i couldn't
i could not like i you know
you you have a lot of these women on
your podcast right like celine selena
power or whatever right allegedly
allegedly by the way
i want to just give you props the plug
talk podcast great idea the only podcast
of its kind where we interview girls and
then [ __ ] them right
so
you and your only plug talk porn man you
and your wife uh is this your this you
guys are officially married now right
beyonce fiance so you and your fiance
slash baby mama you guys just had a baby
shout out to your lady um the podcast
just long was it episode three or four
three just came out with selena powell
uh so we didn't [ __ ] her we had a guy
[ __ ] this is only fans yes exclusive
only plugtalk.com
uh you go and you you interview the
person and sex happens after yeah
is it like continuous off the interview
like is it like
the interviews like all right all right
yo that great interview and then you
just i mean i would kind of like for it
to be that seamless or is it like a cut
and then it's we do a little cut because
we have to take the mics off uh because
we're like wearing different mics like
for the interview part and then we
switch to like a boom mic for the sex
part so there is like a quick break
there but i would like to have it be
totally seamless for the girl cause
that'd be hard plop on top of the dick
right right seamless i think the sema
should be kind of hard yeah cause it no
no no uh no point no no pun intended no
no point proven yeah
but how is it how's that going i mean
amazing we did i honestly think we did
our best scene yesterday with this girl
uh kenzie ann who uh is like a new porn
star or whatever and we just did an
interview she was super cool interesting
person my girl was like hella into her
um so it was that was great i mean
honestly the sign ups are you [ __ ] uh
the adriana i don't even know how to say
her last adriana
her [ __ ] videos are so [ __ ] crazy
bro yeah she's like back in the day
there was like belladonna you remember
belladonna i do belladonna was like that
wild [ __ ] she used to take like
louisville slugger up her ass like she
was like see i wanted to see
[ __ ] had a shaved head she was like
back in the day she was like in the bang
bros era i'd like to call it yeah she
was like the nastiest [ __ ] alive she
would [ __ ] daytime she would have [ __ ]
anybody
she would have let yeah but but anybody
this adriana chick is like man some of
the [ __ ] she'd be doing is like
physically uh unhealthy like yeah that's
what i like about him he's a horny dude
and he'll keep it right you know you
wanna know the coincidence look at the
skin pigmentation y'all [ __ ]
he's not white for the record
if you're going to put him and his whole
history of his people in the same bucket
as mine from a totally different part of
the world that just proves how arbitrary
these racial labels are well what's your
eyes
[ __ ] tell me what a white [ __ ] look
like french and uh
[Laughter]
i thought you were
he said [ __ ]
oh that was great i'm a white man that's
what i said why did i
my wife is she's latin she's mexican
that's why i thought i've seen your kids
i thought you had a black baby mama no i
just always say
you can't block you out there hey he's
still still minority he's still here i
[ __ ] with it
but this [ __ ] acting like y'all
light-skinned white black dark-skinned
white light
[ __ ] it man
did it piss you off he thought she was a
mexican
i just like mexican is weird because i
don't look mexican because you don't
look you don't look at spread again i
just think everybody in l.a is mexican
oh my god this is where i'm at duly
noted
i mean and also not a bad you know not i
mean there's a percentile game there
where you know you're going to be right
more times than not than not for sure
yeah especially here you know just a
shout out to my rosters man shout out to
the razors
no how was uh the adriana chick did
y'all do like some wild [ __ ] like is she
like a normal human being
she honestly she's pretty cool we just
had sex but it was it was fun
five dollars onlyplugtalk.com
damn and then and then the patreon
episodes are different right i got him
acting different in there on the patreon
[ __ ] bro he's crazy bro he paddled some
girl with a book
that was pretty fun sprinkled potato
chips on something so y'all talk about
uh some one of y'all's cameraman got
their ass eating or pegged or something
i wasn't there for that [ __ ] that was
like this he was filming
no he wasn't no no no there's this
youtuber danny mullen and he said that
he wanted the new episode and he had
this filmer that he used this guy cigar
guy and uh cigar guy i guess is into
getting his butt fingered and so the
girl kazumi like was like fingering his
ass but then the crazy part about that
you guys film this yeah
and uh that that like dude disappeared
after this like nobody knows what
happened to him he probably [ __ ]
killed himself got his ass fingered i
mean he knew he was being recorded fell
off the face of the oh my god crazy
right what is that like
was that couch get thrown away
no that couch is clear we clean it and
then some of the employees come and i
think they clean it as well if they plan
on sitting there just don't put your
bare face on there you're gonna get a
sty
oh man you're gonna get pink eye for
sure for sure for sure and the dead
looks i was gonna say like um
[Music]
you know adam you've kind of like done a
good job of like
turning no jumper into like a world i'm
trying man right like you know i feel
like it started off with just you you
being the guy who were who's doing a lot
of these early soundcloud interviews you
know what i'm saying like
um and
i feel like you kind of made a pivot in
the last like i was a year and a half
where you just kind of went all in on
like
building like a
a network award you know what i'm saying
like a lot of effort used to go into the
store and i feel like you know just
dealing with the day-to-day chaos of the
store made it kind of hard for us to
like you know work on that but then
honestly it was a.d like when we brought
him in he is the first person i put on
camera that like really like
like got into it i was like kind of
hyped on doing podcasts and [ __ ] and i
think it was also the pandemic because
he normally would be off like doing a
lot more [ __ ] but he's kind of like you
know stuck in the crib a lot for a few
months there or whatever even though he
is realistically like the person who
ignored the pandemic more than anybody
oh for sure you never caught cover did
you
no i'm not talking i never we don't know
if i had the money
would have it before anyone i knew yeah
bro i probably got it first and didn't
know by the time it came
you know what i'm saying yeah i remember
we were talking about like yo have you
not got coverage yet bro you're [ __ ]
everywhere like we got a good squad now
that we got dunno dude is great
mm-hmm
uh sharp pretty hyped on that
nah duna is great working on some more
um t-reel's the guy who used to roll
with tiger right
that's a that's a that's a pun play
bought him in yeah i'm saying shout out
to pun man bum ass rams
what are you calling
bum ass rams the rams they're oh they
lost to the cardinals in la shout out
tiny cup
hey so how does that work so like you
get your cut of like like you give him a
cut of his show or like how does how
does every is everyone taken care of
yeah yeah it's like percentages and
everything everything real handsomely
nice i'm not complaining
and then your show is called at the end
of the day come on wednesdays um
formerly known as tales from the crypt
no that's what he he my show his idea
for me to have a show was totally
different he wanted me to interview like
gang members old gang members from all
over you to be
the [ __ ] vlad basically
we was like nah [ __ ] i broke the light
the lane is wide open
really i was gonna let you do whatever
you wanted i just i know that was like i
was like you know you should talk to
like these g's that like other people
couldn't get on the podcast and it turns
out he would rather tell poop jokes with
juno and make fun of tyrell's arm and
whatnot but i mean you know
either way yeah there's a thing with his
arm right i'm not crazy it's beautiful
it's beautiful he said he's gonna get
surgery and it's going to be
it's not like a dj paul situation but
it's like no no no no no no
he got like a motorcycle accident yeah
okay okay yeah it ain't work since then
damn that's rough they talk about it on
the podcast every time everyone think it
was like so cruel but he's just down
he's just okay he's just used to it
rosewood i mean we were talking crazy
about each other on the wednesdays no no
i mean listen bro i know how you are
you never watch the show i've watched
the show i haven't watched it much
lately with like two rails because now
he's like a regular on the show right
see really do know yeah no i've seen it
with dunno because duna's been on for a
minute
right yeah yeah yeah you went around the
same time yeah
yeah no dude it's hilarious oh bro bro
it's funny as [ __ ] yeah yeah
so like let me get this straight so the
patreon [ __ ] is usually only fans chicks
right or just like some like ratchet ass
like we're trying to make plug talk more
like
really well-known porn stars or the
girls that we're managing
you're managing girls okay we're
managing a bunch of girls is this
digital pimpin this is digital
management
watch that p word for sure let's not use
that word yeah
so would you so is this like a tiger
like you know tigers trying to do that
[ __ ] right i would i don't know exactly
what he's doing but i would assume it's
probably so are you managing
girls like only fans accounts yeah
well not like running their account but
we're like in charge of promoting them
he's [ __ ] them and then putting them
out there what do you what's your
percentage uh undisclosed nice yeah 75
yo this guy's
if you're a 75 what does only fans keep
like what is it they keep 20 percent
yeah so they keep whatever they keep 20
and then you get your your cut and then
the girls stuck with the pennies all
right i wouldn't say that i'm just
[ __ ] with you we're making these
ladies rich yeah no so like uh
i think the first i think i ain't gonna
say her name but the first girl within a
week she made what 60 grand a month
after that one more time way that was
like the first couple days or something
now
yeah because she has sky bree scott yeah
yeah yeah who are you uh managing are
you managing that asian girl that's
always on your [ __ ] what's your name oh
me no no she's the witch yeah
she's makes a lot of money yeah she
makes a lot more but she's the like you
think what's the adriana girl you said
she ain't doing adriana type [ __ ] nah
she's worse bro she said that she used
to be doing like 50 guy game banks for
fun because that's what she does she got
it but what is it but is it on camera no
when we were at combo scone she kept
pointing out random guys like oh he was
at the gang bang and we're like so this
is real like you really like this i
couldn't believe it until she showed me
a polaroid it was like 13 14 white
[ __ ] it was butt ass nick and it was
her another girl on the bed so i knew
this [ __ ] was crazy
i couldn't
uh
you know i've had opportunities in my
life to be in those situations right
i couldn't do it man but you like them
you like the [ __ ] white you like i
can't do that [ __ ] this [ __ ] he's just
like come on bro let's go you had to ask
me back in the day to pull up to a 50
guy game man i would have been like oh
yeah i'll do that yeah
i'll see you what time what time what
what's what order am i at but i knew
some dudes in new york that would be on
that where they would like be like oh
yeah yo like friday like me and like 12.
we're going to run a train we got a
hotel room in this [ __ ] who's down to
get ran through it's like 50 bucks each
and i would overhear these comments but
i never really went for it so i'm kind
of counting nothing shocks me anymore
being around this guy yeah cause like i
just don't know if i could get into it
you know what i'm saying i'm
desensitized to sex now
it's like it's not like
sacred because of adam or because of
because of adam the stories the [ __ ]
that i see now like the doing the
patreons will make you just lose hope
and all you saw a woman who was as tall
as me put her whole hand in her butthole
and it was bleeding
you keep saying i didn't see blood
and it was bleeding this is on camera
yes that was on the patreon wait the
chick fisted herself she put her hand up
her ass
oh my god
kev has such horny vibes dude i know he
would love hey instead of the dream
champs
and you can watch all the
no
boys
i just i'm just like yo that would be
that would be just like a very
interesting thing to witness i've seen
we've seen a we've seen a was there lube
involved i think she did she worked with
a little kid with a glove oh yeah
somebody
this [ __ ] would be like look let me
show you a trick i can do without like
any prep
this took real skill we seen a girl come
she made herself sport all over the
floor in like three seconds uh that's
piss
well she peed yeah no that's definitely
piss
yo you you
i mean you probably made a girl squirt
in your life for sure
many the next minute the next day got it
the next day you got pissy bed sheets it
smells like piss yeah i mean hey
i had adriana chechi do that to my couch
yeah she [ __ ] she squirted all over
the couch and then afterwards when she
left i'm like well now i got a wet couch
the [ __ ] am i going to do with this when
you sleep on that [ __ ] at my
former apartment yeah oh wow
jesus yeah squirt is definitely urine
and you and it feels good like at the
time and then the next morning you wake
up and you're like
especially if you have kids you're like
yo why does it smell like
oh
gotta wash the sheets you don't want
your kid finding your squirt puddle it's
a squirt puddle or the [ __ ]
that's why when you like like
man mattresses is [ __ ] disgusting you
know what i'm saying bro that's the nice
thing about now that we got multiple
properties is that we don't even have to
do any kind of freak [ __ ] well this
[ __ ] got a studio he got a studio
apartment in his backyard don't let him
fool you we call it the jack shack
the jack shack
what does that mean
think about it you'd be is that is that
well
so basically like there is such thing as
a jack shack which is like basically
like on the side of the highway like
it's like something that's the same club
it would be like a bunch of little boots
where you could like watch a stripper or
some [ __ ] or even like i've heard about
them where they have like porno playing
in the little booth
i mean that's like like an adult
bookstore that kind of [ __ ] yeah and
like we used to always just call it a
jack shack back in the day on bmx trips
and stuff because you would just see him
on the side of the highway and we
thought it's funny as hell i never went
to one and then um he just thought it
was the funniest thing ever when i said
the word jack shack around him and then
when he realized that i have a back
house outside of my house that i have
like my whole streaming setup in it and
everything then he really that's the
jack shack that's a jacket i mean i have
jacked off there so that's fair
i went to uh
when i first moved to vegas i moved to
vegas in 2010.
and uh
i was doing radio there and there was a
peep show place on like las vegas
boulevard and like charleston like by
[ __ ] the pawn stars pawn shop
and me and like six of the homies was
just out partying right it was like when
i first moved there so i [ __ ] were
like yo let's just
i've never been to a peep show i was
like yo let's go check this [ __ ] out it
was the most grodiest [ __ ] ever bro
it was [ __ ]
horrible it's like you said there's like
it's like a circular room
and there's a bunch of booths
you know where you pay you get in and
there's just [ __ ] a real busted down
chick who's
life ain't good for her you know what
i'm saying i mean life ain't working out
and she's just in there [ __ ] with
roast beef curtains just
handling herself
squirting on the glass and
it was disgusting bro it was like you
went to a jack shack i did yeah but i
didn't jack i just was like
it was like i just want to see this [ __ ]
it was actually shaq has ever been to a
jack shack shagging jack now i know a
quick shout out jack don't put that
don't put that evil on shaq man shout
out to shaq i know a girl who used to
hook up with shaq so she said she said
uh what you would think is not the case
well that's what it said in superheads
oh yeah [ __ ] i read superhead's book
back in the day and she said basically
it wasn't all that which you might think
you would assume shaq is swinging i
don't want to hear this [ __ ] i i just
think like your height and your penis
size are like pretty unrelated because i
mean i've had a couple homies over the
years who were like
the shortest dudes with the biggest
dicks right it just happens i don't know
it's just yeah it's genetic man is there
a yo are you are you uncomfortable you
were you [ __ ]
24 7. i'd be like bro dick talk like let
me tell you this is this is part of a
lot of
let me see what he did and i didn't
appreciate this i told don't never do
this [ __ ] again you feel me so
early on me [ __ ] with no jumper right
yeah i get a [ __ ] eye message guess
what he sends me a picture of tiger's
dick i said listen bro we homies and all
but i don't feel this [ __ ] funny because
i saw that too you feel me don't send me
no [ __ ] like this you crossing the
[ __ ] line so sis this is it's just
ridiculous man for radio show prep i was
like
no
that's why he got his head there look at
him we'll go on twitter and [ __ ] and
then like i'll just click on what's
trending and i click on tyga and i saw
his dick and i was like [ __ ] bro that's
not the first thing i want to see in the
[ __ ] morning i copped them i haven't
even had cereal yet these things are
[ __ ] the taco only events yeah how was
it
i mean i don't know i can't even really
remember it's just like a bunch of
photos of him with girls and [ __ ] and
then like he had one photo of his dick i
heard he really be [ __ ] the girls on
there would you rate tigers
listen who is he
are you are you erasing it out of my
mind
who's dick's bigger you were tigers
who's
you and saga got to be eskimo brothers
at least 10 times over it gotta be hey
man this is a nice setup you got right
here i know i am
yo it's funny uh white [ __ ] crazy you
would commented on uh kanye uh
getting his only fans point off of
reddit
right right
because a lot of people
will go on reddit and get
all the only fan [ __ ] or discord or
whatever for free i've heard um
i'm sure that that your shit's probably
on there somewhere i would assume i've
never seen it because i've seen it you
have
my baby mama said is this adam where's
my lawyer it was him i need that [ __ ]
taken down i wanna read it but no but
you had pretty much been like yeah like
that's real [ __ ] funny you know
taking advantage of you know
i just think like if you're a
billionaire or even a millionaire
and you're bragging about how you're
like not paying some girl like eight
dollars to like see your videos that you
apparently like looking at or whatever i
mean like i don't know to me that's just
corny as [ __ ] i'm not gonna like make it
this big [ __ ] stink i know a lot of
people are like accusing me of simping
whatever but i mean to me it's the same
thing as like you know you go to a
restaurant you spend 200 on dinner and
it's like
maybe the waitress didn't really [ __ ]
do [ __ ] but you're still gonna give her
40 bucks for the tip right yeah it's
like i mean i just don't understand how
somebody would think it was like a cool
thing to brag about not paying for that
when it's you know he wants people to
pay for his music right i'm sure if
there was like a mass campaign and
people bootlegging his music he'd be
upset right um i mean it's
same it's close to your heart yeah yeah
well i mean i just a lot of times it
feels like people don't want to stand up
for the girls this is true i stand up
for the girls porn lives matter with him
porn lives matter porn lives matter hmm
you said it first not me how many women
are you managing adam on the uh only fan
side um less than 10 at this time who's
your biggest earner like can you
sky-bird sky bree i'm keep it real on
that she's going crazy
caucasian yeah um
doing some wild [ __ ] or what like what's
what's
she's out there yeah wow
hey man shout out to adam's a hustler
man hey man they got they got some
sisters now too
y'all i mean
i think the first time you came up to
the radio station you brought your lady
and i'm trying to remember uh the name
of the girl uh [ __ ] i know her name but
i can't remember her [ __ ] name real
petite black chick and a fox and a fox
there you go yeah yeah gina
no no it was anna fox who's she just
porn yeah yeah
let me ask you this adam cause like i
feel like you've kind of come along as
far as like
like early on when you really first
started a pop i felt like you stood on a
lot of mountains
like i remember specifically when you
were on the breakfast club
you screaming the like you were on the
little pump mountain screen i've never
been on a breakfast club for the record
you run the breakfast club just so you
ain't messing
no but i went on uh you might be
thinking of brilliant idiots it was
brilliant because charlotte yeah it was
brilliant idiots because you were
talking about you were talking about
rick ross and rick ross not being
relevant remember that i mean i just i
think they asked me crazy they asked me
like
did you hear the new rick ross album and
i was like no like dude it was brilliant
they're like did you hear the new wallet
album like no they're like wow
i'm like i'm just i don't i'm not
listening to them at this point in my
life and i like it's weird how like once
you're in the music industry you have to
like pretend that you listen to all
these legacy artists who are on their
like 14th album like you have to pretend
that you're sincerely like a waiter is
great though shout out to ross i have
nothing against them i've been in the
industry a lot longer so i probably
wouldn't say something like that now but
i was just being real which was like i
listened to a lot of street music
underground music i'm not really
listening to
there's almost no artist that i'm
listening to their [ __ ] eighth album
well we just have it all out of you out
of your system
what the [ __ ] are you doing at that
point
but i was i feel i was going to say i
feel like you've kind of evolved in that
aspect because i feel like early on you
were like
on your mountains with little pump and
you know the no jumper type guys that we
would associate i wrote the soundcloud
wave out but you know at a certain point
i realized like this isn't really about
it's not really about like one
particular genre of music and really
it's not even about like
doing interviews it's really about like
building a business putting a team
together i still love doing the
interviews but i also just like at a
certain point like a lot of this [ __ ]
this just seems kind of silly like you
know i'm like standing on stage like a
16 year old kid and he's chanting [ __ ] j
cole to the audience and it's like i'm
getting blamed for it because i'm the
only person who's 30 in the room
and uh yeah i mean so those like
cert i was i was going to say because
there there was like a a moment where
you know
you were heavily associated with a lot
of stuff that would happen that you
really didn't have anything to do with
so did you kind of
was there like a moment where you were
like you know what i got to kind of step
back a bit from like
being in the mix too much with some of
these kids i mean honestly yeah
definitely like that [ __ ] got old really
quick especially when everybody started
dying from drug overdoses and [ __ ] was
like oh like like you know when i look
at like how i was with pump and purp
where i was kicking it with him drinking
lean popping pills and [ __ ] and then by
the time juice world rolls around it's
like i had a friendship with juice world
i would go to the studio with him it was
cool but then i started to like be kind
of uncomfortable with like this dude's
getting [ __ ] up and this [ __ ] ain't
really like fun or cool i don't feel
like i'm responsible like being around
this kind of stuff because at that point
i wasn't partying i just stopped at one
point like i was drinking doing coke
doing pills all this [ __ ] i just stopped
like a few years ago and just all that
[ __ ] kind of just stopped seeming fun to
me you know
where i'm at in my life like i just
don't want to like see teenagers popping
pills in front of me especially if
you're not like it's like it's like
you're going you know where the studio
sessions are they could be very uh
debaucherous yeah so you're in the
studio and you're you're sober you're
not participating in this [ __ ]
do you feel like with the juice world
[ __ ] like
because i do remember you being in the
studio with him all the time you had a
great relationship with him a couple
times but yeah did you feel like um
like man if i'm if i keep coming around
this [ __ ] like i'm kind of participating
in the negligence yeah and it just
stopped being me like i stopped getting
[ __ ] up so all of a sudden i'm
starting to see [ __ ] clearly which is
like oh like you know i i've been in the
studio with rappers where i've seen them
like really like needing lean like mad
yelling at their friends like upset
about not having lean and then i think
about it like yo like two years ago this
[ __ ] seemed cute to me like i thought
the the lean [ __ ] was all well and good
you know and it's like and i'm saying
this ad is probably thinking this that
he saw me drink lane the other day but
very very rare occasion that way
[ __ ] just don't seem cute after a
certain point you know and for me it's
like at a certain point you know i had a
[ __ ] kid and you know i'm like
serious about my business i wake up at
seven in the morning every day i'm not
he he'll tell you that you can't get me
to leave the house past midnight pretty
much at this point in my life and you've
asked for a phone after eight
yeah i feel like i had that moment too
where it was like yo if i'm not getting
paid or there's not some real play
involved like i'm at the crib man that's
how i be feeling now too you except you
still go out every single [ __ ] night
no i don't
i do i do more business middle of the
pandemic
[ __ ] video goes viral with that dude
cracking that other dude upside down
and i remember saying i think i was with
head and i remember being like i bet a.d
was there and
that one
at the rooftop
i had to stop drinking so it's like the
why did you because the doctor told me
yeah like but the urge to go out
afterwards it's like
now about the logic of it i'd be like
what am i going to do this and get in
some [ __ ] trouble or i can i don't
say like some work on something with you
right because like now you're i mean
you've always been like popping in la
right but like
you're also now like a media personality
mm-hmm so now you kind of experience
what him and i probably expect i mean
i've been doing radios 09 so
[ __ ] sending you their mixtape
or running up on you
yo have me on the show have to get
adjusted to that i had i had to get just
i was turned up on [ __ ] they just like
they broke hockey there i said i don't
do no interviews [ __ ] and people get so
they take [ __ ] so personal bro when
you're just like
it's just crazy like the the lack of
tact
or common sense that artists have
is crazy and entitlement oh entitlement
is number one entire rappers are so
[ __ ] entitled break i don't even know
who you are bro like why like what like
you i'ma just bring you all my [ __ ] like
what like what like and bro everybody
like
like 80 of the artists and people told
me i shouldn't do no jumper i shouldn't
do media nothing like that now like bro
that was the best [ __ ] move i'm like
y'all [ __ ] is stupid bro it's like why
wouldn't you do
you know if you could have the
personality and all the opportunities
are here why wouldn't you put yourself
on camera and i feel dumb not doing [ __ ]
sooner not vlogging now you know what
i'm saying now i look at [ __ ] like him
now i'll be like okay instead of just
playing video games at the house why
don't i [ __ ] film this [ __ ] get some
great content monetize that [ __ ] and
it's like every single aspect is like
now business mind is like okay
let me get a buck for this let me get a
buck for this let me get a buck for this
and it kind of takes away like the play
time from it it's like okay if i'm not
getting paid like even now like i go out
when i'm hosting you know i mean like
and it's [ __ ] life's been better i got
more [ __ ] money i'm not making dumb
ass purchases and [ __ ] like that and i
feel like that respect level too has
gone way up yeah i would all you know
for just like you know shout out to head
but me and edward always like man ad be
putting out so much ill [ __ ] but like
he'd be [ __ ] over exposing himself to
the marketplace
so like when he drops [ __ ] it's like
like you're at every club everywhere
i'm excited to see what it's like when
you put your new [ __ ] out because yeah
he hasn't put up a project in like two
years and i feel like the no jumper
audience is actually like really primed
so like i know support was it was it the
blue rhino [ __ ] last [ __ ] you dropped
that was like that was a ep but i mean
like in the interim of everything bro i
mean by the way those work yeah they
work good yeah me and pun we look too
good yeah me and pum bought our own
bought a studio you know what i'm saying
so i i got the the time to like one
thing that this [ __ ] showed me is that
okay i could film and do all this stuff
but i get to take my time with music
don't have to rush anything yeah i mean
and just really get the best material
out of the situation and it's like i'm
coming back with some of the biggest
producers in music you know what i mean
i got new fans you know what i mean i
still like crazy ass features like
everything is primed and i'm like [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] on my [ __ ] and you could
really rap 1000 people people give you
credit as like a mc because i've heard
some [ __ ] where i'm like yeah this is a
d we went to the studio with him one
time and just watching him like put a
verse together i'm like oh man i totally
forget from hanging out with this guy
and seeing him act like an idiot then
he's really good
hey man hey where'd you get your teeth
done a.d i ain't telling you that but
i'll tell you off camera
bolivia
no nobody do you feel like you kicked
off the teeth away for a lot of people i
know you was clowning me for that [ __ ]
i
we're playing this song on the radio but
then i'd have like the horse gift in the
corner
bro where's like like weird started
calling me the mask and [ __ ] just
started like running with this [ __ ] nah
but
i didn't even like it i didn't even want
to get my teeth were your teeth [ __ ]
up no
i didn't want to get my teeth done i'm
one of them people like prime example
right all right shot the pun pun is like
hey i got this furniture that i need to
go pick up you feel me so we go to pick
up the furniture this type of guy i am
we pick up the front of the chair and
he's like hey i got an extra one i'm
like i want it i don't even know the
[ __ ] it is
you know what i mean so i get the [ __ ]
he's like do you even know what you
bought i'm like nah i don't know what i
bought i just want that [ __ ] so that's
how i am i ended up going to this place
i happened to just be there traveling
my homeboy wherever it was my homeboy
was getting his teeth done and it was
like hey
we know you we could do your [ __ ] too i
was like let's do it
and i ran with that [ __ ] that's the
weirdest thing is like i'll never notice
like most people who get the new teeth i
don't notice they ever had bad teeth for
the most part there's a few people
who i'm like yeah you needed that but
most of the time i'm like i never
noticed anything was wrong with your
teeth my [ __ ] wasn't like
it wasn't like it was but i noticed when
you have them [ __ ] chompers you know
what i'm saying this is nice though but
look it was funny though because i did
uh um
snoops uh the gg news right yeah and
somebody wrote back was like hey these
teeth was [ __ ] up and i kind of like
made fun of myself and screenshotted but
my tv went bad it was more on the
yellowish side you know i'm saying a
little tainted
but yeah i'm perfect it's called being
an adult you know what i'm saying now
[ __ ] that [ __ ] when the hair go i'm i'm
getting the full treatment too maybe
everything's fake i'm gonna have
everything bro we gotta strike back now
the beard ain't fake this [ __ ]
and people think of my beard
[ __ ] weird
fake beard no i gotta always
he had a friend who took like uh
like they took some sort of
graph from the back of his head
and now he has an entire on his beard
his whole beard is it's like real hair
oh they like fill it in but he had to do
like a real like he had to do surgery
but now he's got like a perfect beard
[ __ ] fire i was insecure about my
hairline before i got the surgery done
but uh when i think about it being
insecure about your beard has got to be
pretty weird wait you got a surgery done
yeah i got the thing bro we had a pride
out of this [ __ ] man he got two
two hair jobs man
yeah is that why you were always bald
um i i i okay so 2011 i think i got the
hair transplant done and so i was like
28 then and that's before anybody even
knew who i was and then as time went by
it started to look a little bit more
whacked so i started shaving my head for
a couple years but i still had a decent
hairline around that time but then i got
it done again and that brings us to
today except i died of blonde
are you scared of diet back
uh
i kind of want to dive on again because
i kind of like it i kind of feel like
it's making me like have more fun you
know blondes have more fun oh my god
yeah yo so i um what
i was just at dame dash's place the
other day we did an interview my guy um
and everyone was dming me like yo did
you have to pay for the interview
i was like
nah but i was gonna pay because he
wanted money to pull up on us right even
though i went to him he lived like 10
minutes away right but you guys were
gonna do like uh you guys did like at
least one episode of you guys doing
something i remember watching it three
what what ended up happening like what
went wrong there what didn't i mean i
guess um
i just basically ended up feeling like
i was not gonna get anywhere with like
building
rapport you know which is what i'm
really into is i like that
what i'm attracted to with podcasting
like repeatedly like with people like
him and house phone and stuff is that
you feel like you just keep making the
relationship better and deeper and
stronger and then eventually you look at
something like joe budden podcast and
why it was kind of like traumatic when
they broke up is because you know you
really had gotten used to seeing that
dynamic over and over and with dame i
just kind of eventually started to feel
like there was no
way that we were going to actually get
anywhere so i just kind of like why
waste time
yeah it just didn't really stand out to
me as something that i really wanted to
be doing and so i just kind of do you
look at um
obviously you're a hip-hop podcast right
at its core but do you kind of like
do you even look at yourself through
that scope anymore as a rap podcast yeah
i do and i'm still doing a shitload of
interviews
even though
i sometimes feel like i really don't
need to be doing this like you know i
have like actually other things i could
be doing with my time that are like a
lot more profitable because we'll
interview some of the same people and
some of the same people we interview
are horrible to talk to uh-huh
right so
you know sometimes sometimes some people
[ __ ] some people are just they're just
you know they're just kids and yeah
it is what it is i still like you know i
feel like
i take a lot of pride in interviewing
people that i've seen do other
interviews that sucked right and then
being able to get like a much better
version of them out and i think it's all
about just making them feel as
comfortable as possible and you know
that i really like doing interviews like
when i think about my life when i think
about like what would i change if i had
a [ __ ] 100 million dollars dropped in
my bank account tomorrow like would i
stop doing interviews like no way i i
probably wouldn't like stress out about
it as much you know maybe i would like
you know go a couple weeks without doing
one sometimes but i definitely would
keep doing interviews i love you i love
doing interviews too but what's the last
time you did an interview
during the interview you were like what
the [ __ ] am i doing oh jesus if i looked
at my schedule i could probably find
some of those i know who it is really
air it out maybe fake drake
that's but that was just so funny to me
i just knew because that was as short as
[ __ ] i was like [ __ ] 30 minutes i gave
him half an hour because i felt like
that's not terrible you don't need an
hour what else yeah we're not going to
talk to you i didn't see it i don't know
he's telling me about his crypto
business and [ __ ] and i'm like this is
kind of interesting because we're
actually like i like doing the meme
interviews like that for sure the dude
who made the fake the the song where he
like acted like he was leaking all of my
personal life
and i did an interview with him and like
acted like i was mad at him and kind of
acted like it was like a real thing and
it got a shitload of views and everybody
was like i can't believe i'm 22
interviewed the dude who exposed his
social security number like it was all
fake he knew he he knew some facts
though he knew some facts he didn't know
[ __ ] about me okay he did not know one
thing he's talking about like i robbed
his grandma my grandma's have both been
dead for like 20 years but he said he
said the car that you used to drive dude
what's weird is the um that random white
dude you had on your podcast that i
think you're beefing with now
uh milk oh milk
bro he's homeless
that dude like you did you guys did that
interview yeah and then he started dming
me like
every day
like yo yo i was on adam 22 let me come
up and i and i was like yeah bro i'm
good you know like and then the dude
just started like bashing me on his
instagram yo he does that to everybody
it's honestly he's like
mental condition yeah because he's
scared of you but he like uh he like
really like does that to everybody that
does anything for him because i like
no matter how much he asked him he
couldn't come up with anything that i
did to him to make him upset he just
tripped out
so i mean
honestly he's a lost soul
is there has there been that situation
for you where you've like because i feel
like you know you look at like
the crit mac dude who i feel like
is his own
thing now he's like like yeah and and i
first obviously saw him and his
personality and how funny he was on no
jumper
has there been a situation where you
feel like you've
kind of helped
bring people you know some attention
that they might not have otherwise
gotten
but but the second that something
doesn't necessarily go their way they
they they get combative with you
honestly like there's been so many
people where when i look at it i kind of
i don't say like i gave them a career
because everybody like you know [ __ ] mac
was who he was in the first place i just
helped to shine a light on it and then
you know channel five does content with
him and that shines a big ass light on
him etc you know that's just it's not
like i [ __ ] invented him or made him
or anything like that but yeah like
almost all the time people are really
cool about that and like you know they
see that for what it is and they're
appreciative of the fact that you helped
them to get somewhere you're not going
to do the whole thing for them obviously
there's a lot of work for you to do once
you get your no jumper interviewer you
get your vlad interview but we see it
all the time where you know i see so
many older gangster dudes or even like
you know people in other ways of life
who've been on vlad a couple times and
then all of a sudden you fast forward a
couple years and they use that to launch
their own podcast and they all of a
sudden have a big old revenue stream and
a business for themselves and that's a
beautiful thing you know and like
i would you know almost everybody like
sees that dynamic and respects and
appreciates it milk is the rare
[ __ ] who basically like
sees that and doesn't like get it he's
like oh you did something for me but
you're not gonna keep doing things for
me so now i hate you
where like anybody with common sense
would be like oh you did something for
me
i'm gonna stay on good terms with you
because like yo because i would have
kept [ __ ] with them i would have kept
you know this is why i don't like beef
is crazy i mean he's just like you're
looking at a dude who i mean he told me
about in the interview he obviously had
like a super [ __ ] up childhood and i
don't think he like knows how to be
loved he doesn't know how to like have
somebody do something nice for him and
then return that and reciprocate and
like have a healthy
bond between people because you're
talking about somebody that has no
friends he's not like respected or like
allowed back where he's from et cetera
none of those people [ __ ] with him at
all it's like i mean it's pretty
transparent like if you watch his
content or whatever that he doesn't have
any relationships you know um not to say
that at the moment you can't like help
make a rapper's career because no
jumper's still one of the biggest platf
but i feel like 2018 2017 it was like a
thing that if you went on no jumper it
could like break your career but it was
weird because that was the time period
where the the industry in general was
like cutting like three million dollar
advances like there are artists that i
know that i could name right now that
you have never heard of that had one
song on that on elevator or on [ __ ]
no jumper or whatever and they got three
million views and then or whatever and
the label gave them millions of dollars
because there was a crazy [ __ ]
bidding war between the labels and a lot
of those artists literally never put out
another song that did like a million
views like that was never anything yeah
it's insane
the industry got so [ __ ] up then and i
feel like it's really come back to earth
because like the bidding war thing is
kind of going well like i always refer
to like 2017 2018 is like the
it was just rough for rap music because
like there was like you said like there
was like labels just signing instagram
dudes yeah and trying to turn them into
rappers and sometimes it worked because
that's what pump was pumped was like a
funny like meme thing like with like a
song
and they signed them and you know like
what was that one dude um like kid boo
like he got signed off of him being a
clone he didn't get signed did he
yeah was he assigned to uh you signed an
island
was he yeah
that's so sad
you think of [ __ ] like that and you're
like
[ __ ] man
like and people in that same vein were
getting bagged up yeah and it was all
like
total nerd ass kids who just dyed their
hair and then just started talking about
spraying up your block yeah like skinny
from the nine got a deal you know from
hico you know what i'm saying real
gangster but uh you know a lot of these
other people were like this is just the
most random kids ever just talking about
drugs talking about whatever and now
when you look at it who's the most
popular rapper so usually like actual
like real street dudes who like are
maybe not even saying stuff that's that
different from the lyrical content of
the soundcloud wrappers but it's like a
real thing well also i feel like um
the cream always rises to the top if we
think of who's always consistent it's
the it's the [ __ ] who really
have like artistic integrity it's always
gonna be that though you know what i'm
saying all that cookie cutter [ __ ] lasts
for a little while where do you think
pump the pump [ __ ] went left because you
were very close to that situation and i
mean
i feel like at one point in time you
were his you were he's probably his
biggest public co-sign yeah
and the [ __ ] definitely went left
i mean it's kind of hard to identify
when exactly that happened because it
was like he seemed so big until all of a
sudden it just
wasn't like he put out that that album
that didn't really sell that good and
it's like everybody just kind of saw
that and like got in on this like
bandwagon thing of like his career's
over [ __ ] him
i mean i was just kind of observing it
you know i never had anything bad to say
about him like i was you know i thought
there were a bunch of missteps you know
i thought that like what was that one
song that was like a he was dressed like
a doctor and the whole video was like
way too many drugs in the video oh it
was it was literally
it was like about it was something about
drugs it was like uh [ __ ] it was like
drug addicts yeah drugs
and i was like
i don't know man this just seems like
people are not going to [ __ ] with it
like the spanish song he did well that's
what he's doing he's doing a lot of
things
like i was i've seen on his youtube
channel he's got he put out like an emo
song and he put out like a spanish song
i feel like he got to a point where he
was just like when when the music
started to slip away you would notice he
was just leaning heavy into ig antics
just to just to get yeah he was like
like i was like yo man like but what
about the donald trump [ __ ] that was
legendary i felt like that was probably
one of the biggest missteps in terms of
like making people really not [ __ ] with
you i felt like the trump thing was like
[ __ ]
straight out the simpsons [ __ ] that
she's crazy little pimp
that was you know at all the wild [ __ ]
that happened that trump did and he did
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] right i remember
waking up in the morning or like about
to go to bed looking at twitter and just
seeing that video and like just like
this
and the [ __ ] milk boys out on
stage at presidential like what the [ __ ]
world
i think pump got a comeback in them
though you think so yeah
why not he's got only fans
he's you know i heard he's [ __ ] on
there did you pay for it i haven't seen
it but somebody told me the other day's
[ __ ] on there so i should probably
cop
i saw he'd be with a v-rod all the time
yeah i think that's his babe or some
[ __ ] i've seen him saying some real
sweet stuff about her on the story i
don't know i don't know if they're like
dating or if they just do content
together i was gonna say that during
that time
like i'm sure
you had so many opportunities to get a
bag to do an interview
like
what was the biggest bag you said no to
from
i've never even started the conversation
so it was never even like
someone offered it was just like no i'm
not doing it
so i never really
never like heard out dollar amounts
because i just i never even had the
conversation
fair um now that you're you know
obviously
diving into patreon only fans what what
what what like
in your weekly basis right outside of
being a father and hanging with your
wife and [ __ ] what professionally do you
enjoy doing the most right now
um
honestly that's a good question like
it's kind of i still love doing the no
jumper interviews i feel like that's
more of like a passion thing although
like you know yesterday we interviewed
this girl and [ __ ] the [ __ ] at her
afterwards and i mean
that was [ __ ] great like i had a ball
doing that i don't know it's like i
really like everything i'm doing right
now like the the hard part is to control
my
desire to go play poker every day and
like focus on work because
playing poker would be like a really
sad use of my time at this point yeah i
mean gambling is addictive man it is and
it's just you got better with that [ __ ]
though for a minute that [ __ ] had a
laptop right there there's nothing like
it in between [ __ ] pull that
[ __ ] out be doing that [ __ ] yeah
it's like drugs man when you hit yeah
but when you're down it's like the worst
because you're like what could i have
done with that money i just do that in
vegas
like i could have bought i could buy
anything with this money like i could
have
got pizza like any like literally
anything like a watch whatever the [ __ ]
yeah and like you know when i go to the
casino and sit down like 10 20 000 it's
like you lose that and you're like
that's like what my mom was making at
her job when i was a kid like in a year
just lost it over a [ __ ] card well
and online you don't have the actual
physical money with you so it's easier
to [ __ ] off money online yeah oh yeah
super easy most ever lost in a day is
like 15k though so i feel like that's
pretty good though that's not bad that's
not bad
that's not terrible but i've also like
won like 35 in a day too so with all of
like you you deal with so much uh
situations that i feel like you you
leave yourself open to possibly having
like women say some [ __ ] about you in an
era where there's so much canceled
culture [ __ ] going on are you very
conscientious of
of those kind of situations and making
sure like yeah definitely like uh you
know we make the girls sign forms on
forms like you know basically consent
everybody who's on set has to sign forms
that basically like are them agreeing to
be there and be part of this and
everything like that
so i mean honestly we just do everything
on the up it's like you can't you can't
really predict because once in a while a
girl is just gonna decide like i'm just
gonna say the craziest [ __ ] ever about
you all you can really do is protect
yourself on a legal uh and but i'm also
very confident that right now if a girl
were to come out and say oh something
[ __ ] up happened on the plug talk set
or like whatever it's like you you
signed all this paperwork and we have
video of you from the moment you [ __ ]
you fisted yourself it is what it is you
can't really say anything like
realistically if you try to sue me i'm
probably going to sue you back so go for
it you know i feel like it's just man
you know we we talk about this [ __ ]
because we're like for the radio show
we're like we want to bring a female
co-host on but i also don't want to like
say the wrong joke in front of somebody
i mean talk to your attorney or whatever
and just get contracts that basically
say
part of the job is me saying offensive
things around you you know
like this is the podcast like i i don't
even know if that's really in our
contract because it's just so common
sense that like you know like
if you're gonna hire somebody to have
these conversations on camera with you
it is what it is now like
them getting hit on that's the kind of
stuff they're like you know we have a
bunch of girls who work for us and i
mean
everybody knows this is not like you're
not allowed to use this job as like a
way to get [ __ ] these girls feel
uncomfortable or anything like that like
we're super on top of that but we also
keep like a a giant wall between the
plug talk thing and the no jumper thing
like you know almost all the employees
like go home when we do the plug the
patreon episodes and everything because
you know our our next spot we're going
to be able to do it where it's like
completely sectioned off so there's no
chance of them seeing the girls or naked
or whatever but we try to keep all this
[ __ ] completely separate wait hold on
time to stop the interview because we
got to talk about our good folks at odd
socks man listen if you go to
oddssocksofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev alright at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them um you at
a certain point had a deal with atlantic
yeah and i remember you put out the
record with tay k and block boy jb right
should we play it on real ninety two
three oh my god how much they pay you
for that nothing no i just played it for
you we played it as a new join of the
day yeah it was cool
correct me if i'm wrong right there was
those old accusations that came out
and atlantic kind of washed their hands
of that situation we had like a one-year
contract with our one-year addition to
it where it's like an option to like do
another year and after the first year
they basically
were like they just had like hell of
pressure being put on them by like
journalists and [ __ ] have just kept
hitting them up for [ __ ] comments how
do you feel about this yada yada and
it's like there's so much [ __ ]
bureaucracy in that [ __ ] that's so much
like you know it's hard to make things
move you know like if they have like if
you have like the budget and the team
fully behind you it just ended up being
more trouble than it was worth because
they were dealing with all this weird
[ __ ] from journalists trying to get them
like to
basically they had like journalists
trying to get them to cut me off and
it's like we did that one record we did
like another record it was kind of
whatever i personally and i know it's
like convenient for me to say this some
people might think i'm lying i hated
everything about the experience it was
[ __ ] terrible i started to realize
like very early on that i didn't get the
deal that i could have got should have
got and that if i was really gonna do
this i wanted to do it my own way you
know like they were trying to sign an
artist i tried to sign draco they're
like he's too gang related i'm like
well what the [ __ ] am i even doing here
then you know like this is not you know
like if you're gonna tell me that the
artist being too gang
means i don't get to sign them what the
[ __ ] did you sign me for because that's
not i didn't like what year was that get
into this to do like some safe [ __ ] you
know that's not like i want to sign an
artist that i believe in and obviously
if i had signed draco my life would have
been full of many many headaches as a
result of it so they probably spared me
some some headaches but you know it's
just it wasn't really a good fit to be
honest
i know how to do all that [ __ ] i was
gonna say like i just don't really care
because i don't really see
the value like the times that i've seen
an artist that we could sign and i
really started to conceive of how much
work it was going to be
and how uncertain them becoming a big
star was
and then how much money i'm making doing
other things i just could not like do
the math that would the bandwidth that
you would have to put into it and i'm
already based on the risk so many things
and it's like a lot of times i just look
at my life and somebody comes with me a
business opportunity and i'm like that
is a great [ __ ] idea and i do not
have the time and there's no way like
you're gonna make if you do that right
you can make millions of dollars off
that idea
but i just don't i i really don't
believe that i'm going to be able to
invest myself in it you know and i
remember talking to uh
sasha stone about like he was trying to
get you to do a no jumper festival at a
certain point in time right
wasn't that being tossed around we
talked about a little bit but i mean
honestly everybody in their [ __ ] mom
has talked to me about doing a festival
together or whatever and it's just such
a flooded market and like my whole thing
is like i'm not really trying to bring
anything to market as a business if it's
not gonna like
have a really unique
value proposition you know like when i
think about like
oh do another festival in l.a it's like
well there's already five million
[ __ ] festivals in la and if we're
gonna book artists we're basically going
to end up booking all the same artists
that are playing all these other
festivals and they got exclusivity
contracts so we're not going to be able
to book a lot of them and it's just
i don't know like people always want me
to do all the businesses that other
people that are basically like in my
position are doing like they see rolling
loud and they're like well couldn't you
do a rolling cloud and it's like
maybe i could dedicate my life to trying
to like clone their business model but
they seem like they're doing a great job
well they also have been concert
promoters for you know
the world like literally what they
they're doing a great job does the world
really need me to do like another
version of that same thing and i respect
it like i've seen cole go through the
whole thing and doing the summer smash
thing and he's definitely building this
like big valuable ip out of that just
doing this concert
consecutively but like i never really
like wanted to do that
so i was gonna say uh you could only do
so many things you know how uh
i remember there was the video that came
out when cole stopped by the shop okay j
cole j cole right right and that was
kind of like a a cool moment because at
the at that moment it felt like there
was two
there was such a division in rap music
at that time like a ha
i mean you know when i was a kid there
was like
you would think of like commercial [ __ ]
and then you would think of like
backpack [ __ ] like raucous records and
and like the idea of like
jay-z and tulip quality doing a song
together was so crazy back then even
though that
it would make sense for the do for them
to do a song together right but it was
just a thought but like i feel like that
was kind of a cool moment because it was
very like
it
brought two worlds together right um
this was before cole interviewed pump
that was random like uh
you mentioned sasha he was like talking
to j cole and like j cole was kind of
finding out about no jumper at that time
and was interested in it and i think
sasha told him like you should pull up
to his shop and one of the unfortunate
things about having a shop is that like
you're just not gonna be there every
second of the day and at that time i was
there like [ __ ] eight hours a day
very very consistently but i i just
wasn't there it was like noon or some
[ __ ] you know they just opened and one
of the employees calls me they're like j
cole's here he's he's asking if you're
here and i'm just like what the [ __ ] so
i have to i'm literally like getting in
the shower as i get this call i [ __ ]
hop out the shower i race there i'm
totally out of breath
and all of a sudden i'm talking to j
cole and like
he says like oh like you know like
somehow he asked me what podcast i just
been listening to because i mentioned
something about it and i i mentioned
like i was just listening to this
podcast about religion and so all of a
sudden he's asking me about religion and
like trying to figure out what i think
about religion and [ __ ] and i'm just
like why the [ __ ] did i bring up
religion and also uh like become an
atheist so it's like me too we're
probably not on the same page
and uh and then like you know it's just
kind of like weird because in the
footage i'm like hella out of breath
honestly that editing that i edited it
myself
was the most painful thing i think i've
ever edited like i'm cringing out of my
[ __ ] skin while i edit it because i
was just
awkward not compared i'm not prepared
for that conversation i have no idea and
we talked for like 20 minutes or some
[ __ ] and then he just like went out took
photos of everybody for some reason i
remember i see narco was there that day
and j cole another one of those guys
who's got a bag that he probably
shouldn't have gotten yeah
and then uh no hair but there's photos
of them together he was taking photos of
everybody no security just his manager
just them too chilling and like since
then i can honestly say though that
he's like the rare person that i've met
that i actually just stay in touch with
and we'll just randomly talk about some
[ __ ] or i'll i'll send him an artist
like just hey like hey you should check
this out i sent him rimble he's like wow
this kid's dope like he was super hyped
on it and no
you know like i i [ __ ] i think he hit
me up about [ __ ] mac at one point he did
just saying like yo like is that guy for
real like this is the funniest [ __ ] i've
ever seen like he couldn't believe it
and even like
i decided to shoot my shot fairly
recently this is a boo like that
exclusive i shot my shot i hit j cole up
i said yo the tour is coming through how
would you feel about doing the interview
while you're out here because we had
talked about it before and it basically
said that he was kind of down you know
and like i asked him
and didn't get a response for like four
days or five days and i'm in hawaii
and he just calls me and he actually
like is the rare you know rappers are if
they don't want to do the interview they
just ignore you right of course nine
times out of ten maybe if your homies
with them they'll give you a little
explanation whatever he actually called
me and talked to me for 10 minutes about
how life was going and also was just
like
you know like i think he just really
values his privacy at this point which i
totally get because we're on that level
of stardom you know just everything is
different you know and uh we actually
just had like a real conversation about
that and he was he was just kind of like
you know
i'm not saying i'm never going to do it
and i really respect everything you you
guys got going on but
i just don't really feel like right now
is the time you know i'm not saying i'm
never going to do it like i i just have
never got that level of like
graciousness right like that is like a
nice gracious no yes like i respect what
you do he's like one dude who's so rich
and successful and famous and just
somehow like every interaction i've had
with him
like
there's just no evidence of him being
aware of the position that he's in he's
just actually the nicest no he's the
best yeah like i don't know it tripped
me out man honestly he didn't have to
like call and talk to me and have this
super nice conversation about our kids
for 10 minutes
as a way of saying that he wasn't gonna
do the interview you know i was just
kind of blown away what's what's the
biggest uh
almost interview that happened because i
know you've been in contact with drake
before like was there ever a situation
where something big almost happened and
just for whatever reason it just fell
through last minute like
there's probably been so many yeah like
the drake one he said he wanted to do
that at one point and that just never
happened um when i think about it like i
remember there was one day where we were
doing like a random like uh chill
conversation episode at the store
downtown
and as soon as we get done the employee
at the store says
yo there's like a fan here he wants to
take a photo like are you down i go okay
i walk out it's playboy cardi um it's
like 2015. my [ __ ] employee didn't
know who played where cardi was at that
time my 2016 but either way he's like on
a bike he's on like a a complete bike
that he had borrowed from shane gonzalez
from midnight studios
and he was he it wasn't like it was
anything crazy was just like chill talk
for a minute or whatever and uh there's
like a photo of him on the bike in front
of the no jumper sign and everything
and uh yeah like i even i talked to him
about doing an interview a couple times
back then but it was like a kind of
thing where i really really think i
could have done it i just needed to try
a little harder because we even had the
conversation of him being like i don't
want to do an hour but i'll do 20
minutes and i was like okay yeah we did
we interviewed him uh at the station
like in 2018
yeah and
he was one of those guys that i don't
know like and i'm not like a
playboy cardi is one of the artists
who i'm just i just throw the papers in
the air i don't get it i don't get it my
little brother is like he's the greatest
but i really really liked him in the
early days it's just i don't get it got
a little too weird like like the whole
lot of red [ __ ] i listened to it and i
was like
this is
this i don't i just don't get this [ __ ]
i got a little pump i would listen to
little pump [ __ ] and i believe [ __ ]
bangs like you know what i'm saying but
at that time i totally agree those songs
were knocking right no but that's also
the same time where like even real
gangsters are going up to gummo in the
club you know like party [ __ ] was very
you know but but we when we interviewed
him like it was like a rough interview
right i think he did not want to be
there i think every interview he's ever
done has been rough yeah he just didn't
want to be there uh
nice guy but the big boy interview was
like rough you know like it probably
would have sucked but it would still be
pretty legendary i think too like with
radio like you know like
sometimes we would deal with is like
imagine you're an artist then you're on
a promo run with the label oh yeah and
you go to
99 by the way radio's [ __ ] dying
right so which is why i pivoted and i'm
doing it the way i'm doing it
but
imagine if you're i mean you've been on
promo runs but like imagine if you
you've gone to 30 radio stations and
it's a bunch of corny middle-aged
[ __ ]
so i hear you're a [ __ ] what's that like
yeah so
so i see you got a you know i see you
got a acon on the album how did that
happen i heard he's got his own city
yeah
so that's i hate promo runs i almost
like want to institute that as a rule
like i will only interview you at a time
in your career where you don't have
anything to promote
right well they're not actually but like
you kind of you know come on it happens
we're like [ __ ] there'll be times where
somebody will leave here and go to you
or they'll leave you and come to me and
we'll be like well [ __ ] i mean we do
different types of [ __ ] if you're doing
bootleg kev no jumper and vlad and
you're wearing the same hoodie then
every single i mean like the fulio [ __ ]
like julio's wearing the same outfit and
everything yeah
i'm like that [ __ ] had that
outfit on for a whole week
put on layers and then just take the
layers off throughout the day dude it
and then and then like the youtube
comments are so funny like yo this guy
definitely was just doing every
interview in l.a it's funny when it's
that transparent i've done it though too
i've done like promo runs where i do
like five interviews in a day where i'm
just wearing the same [ __ ] well you do
that in real life anyway yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] you wash your jeans
no he doesn't not that often you should
i mean you really shouldn't unless
they're dirty i mean you got have you
got black jeans you take them again how
many times you got a brand new pair of
miries how many times you're wearing
them before you wash them a mirrors i'm
not washing them ever i'm getting them
dry clean oh yeah at least or once every
two weeks or something i only wash my
pants if they get dirty my denim if i if
i'm like okay they're dirty
or like it's been i'm just i'm just like
you wash black pants they're out of here
no yeah cause like these jeans i'm
wearing right now are like 700 [ __ ]
davinci jeans and it's like i'm gonna
wear them
i'll say you know maybe 96 times maybe
10 times until they start to feel kind
of gross and oily and then i'll probably
dry clean them you know but like hands
feel oily
if you wear them enough they just start
to feel gross they don't feel like clean
you know but i but i'm not getting there
wearing them like four times now if i
bust a sweat in them that's different
because brian bmx back in the day
i really would feel like i would get a
pair of jeans and it would basically be
like my pair of jeans for like the next
like
three weeks
because they're they're just getting
trashed no matter what you know and then
like you wash them and you try to keep
wearing them but i would just [ __ ]
destroy my pants back then
yeah i just feel like jeans like unless
they're dirty i just just fold them back
up and put them in the drawer we live in
a jean culture where you just got you
have no social standing unless you have
four thousand dollar amiri jeans on i'm
not a part of that culture you don't
[ __ ] with that okay you got some
wranglers bro i have like
80 pairs of jeans i only wear three i go
to uh
i get my denim from i don't know zara i
remember tax stone saying jack stone
said
you gonna catch a body
go in and do 20 years they're gonna [ __ ]
your baby mama and all you're gonna have
to show for it is a bunch of pairs of
jeans i was like wow there's some real
[ __ ] that is some real [ __ ] well there's
a lot of people where all of their
life's work is basically in their gene
podcast man hey man if you it sucks like
his situation man cause i really feel
like
his [ __ ] was just getting started man i
talked to him the other day he's in good
spirits
yeah we were supposed to i don't know
why we were supposed to have um troy was
supposed to be here on tuesday well
there's another one that called out on
both of us
he was supposed to come in yeah
see we would have troy having the same
outfit i'm outing myself that i talked
attacks before the troy avenue but
whatever
yeah yeah
is there any like
when you have personal relationships
with certain people
and like you know
they're like your friends right right
and there's like some actual beef [ __ ]
involved will you talk to the hell yeah
yeah we're not friends unless you could
[ __ ]
at least allow me to ask you that you
know if you don't know it's not even
that i mean like will you talk to
their ops
oh
i mean a lot of times the [ __ ] is about
[ __ ] they're so stupid that it's not
like you're going to learn anything from
talking to the ops it's like oh i just
mean like yo like your baby mama or
whatever like have you ever had like a
situation where someone came on your
show and like one of your homies who was
also a rapper felt some type of way
she's like yo you know this dude you
know what i'm saying sometimes it's on
the [ __ ] off like not like that but i'll
be like i'm doing my job yeah i'm like
bro nobody bigger than a pro i've had to
tell rappers that like
this is bigger than whatever personal
grievance you have going on right now i
know your hood don't get along with
their hood whatever but like you gotta
understand all that [ __ ] is just up in
the air like y'all not getting along
right now whatever even if y'all are not
gonna get along for 20 years it has
nothing to do with me you know and it's
like leave me the [ __ ] out of it i just
saw a young boy said he would do a song
with six nine yeah i saw that uh
i know that you've kind of been pretty
adamant that you wouldn't do a six nine
interview right
i don't really know what to say to him
[Laughter]
well i know that like vlad just kind of
pivoted
from his position of saying that he
would never do it when he was on
academic [ __ ] he was essentially saying
you know what i thought about it
i would do the interview
you still wouldn't do the interview
i personally don't really want to take
that on i would i would like to see vlad
do it vlad is extremely well researched
you know i think that he would ask the
questions that i would like to hear you
know i don't think i i feel like 69
wouldn't do it because
he doesn't want to have to withstand
that kind of scrutiny you know i think
like if anything that's just going to
expose him more so myself personally i'm
over him as a human
uh but i would like to see vlad do that
honestly i wonder if a young boy did the
song like does that like really [ __ ]
with his well you got to see the context
of what he said i didn't i only i only
saw the headline so like everything else
the context was he'll do a a song with
six nine before doing it with all these
[ __ ] ass rappers that's basically what
he was saying who's the [ __ ] ass rapper
he just basically said he don't respect
the industry like a mainstream right now
so he said he'd rather do a song with
six nine to do songs with like the top
guys in hip-hop right now
yeah
that's an interesting take i could see
that
i mean i feel like young boy is like
so
gangster and so like
isn't the most gangster thing you could
do to be to not give a [ __ ] about what
anybody else thinks you know so i mean i
get that that's
something he would like to say but i i i
like that context too because that
really kind of illuminates what he was
actually
trying to say in that situation he don't
do no interviews like he don't do
nothing clubhouse the best that i could
get out of them you know you wanted them
on the podcast and you got a clubhouse
instead yeah
hey the clubhouse [ __ ]
are you still in clubhouse [ __ ] no bro i
deleted that [ __ ] after like a week bro
one
one day with that i said this is going
to be bad clubhouse virgin never touched
[ __ ] bro they had a la they had a la
room
i think head was running this [ __ ] bro
me
game
ot
[ __ ] j305 a gang of [ __ ] l.a
artists bro and then [ __ ] shiggy
comes in bro the clubhouse room bro
like the dancer yeah bro shout out to
shiggy man cool [ __ ] but bro
the jokes and they was flaming them
tyrese came in it was just like if it
seemed like the la chat room clubhouse
room was all shaky's ass bro and i felt
bad afterwards because i'm like damn
[ __ ] just [ __ ] i just thought to
myself like this is a big waste of time
like i would see people literally just
on clubhouse all [ __ ] day that were
supposed to be like
you know important people or people who
are you would the perception is that
they're out here doing [ __ ] and i'm like
you're on clubhouse 12 hours of [ __ ]
day like like i i would be
this is real life like i would be in the
office i would do four interviews in the
course of a day i'm on camera for you
know five six hours i'm [ __ ] talking
to my employees and working on other
[ __ ] in between et cetera made all this
content i'm driving home i'm feeling
really good you know i just got the four
[ __ ] podcasts done i'm gonna drop
four episodes next week that's just
tight i felt like i just climbed a
mountain right and then i got people
texting me like do this clubhouse room
and i'm like so you're telling me that
i'm about a podcast i'm about to go home
and i want to sit on the couch and watch
something on netflix and zone the [ __ ]
out and you're basically telling me that
you want me to do
my job for a couple more hours like
yeah but but this is the thing clubhouse
was great for people for people who
had something to say and wanted to put
it out there but didn't necessarily
maybe have a platform because i mean
you're talking about whack 100 tyreese
and shiggy except if you put bullet
cable with those three people they're
going to do a a podcast episode that a
million people can watch that
[ __ ] put it on clubhouse for free i
don't get it
yeah i just felt like it was people just
wasting i i mean it's obviously it's
still a thing right yeah it's kind of
had a little resurgence recently because
i feel like it was kind of dead in the
water for a minute but it's good for
people who want to network like if you
desperately are i just feel like i said
i feel like it's [ __ ] network i just
see [ __ ] talking [ __ ] on there and i'm
like man listen i don't want anybody
talking to me crazy because i love it
the game was like hosting some late
night creep [ __ ] with a bunch of this
[ __ ] is trash
delete this [ __ ] i'm glad i've never
been on there people keep trying to
somebody said to me the other day like
we're working on a clubhouse competitor
uh how much money do you need to to do a
weekly chat wait do you remember the
name of the company no but i just i was
like just looking at it and i'm like
thinking about like what i would
actually need to get paid to do that
[ __ ] twitter twitter doing this [ __ ]
too yeah i'm like it's a lot bro i'm
like i'm not even going to tell you i
don't even know how i ended up in
keemstar's [ __ ] twitter clubhouse
thing i don't [ __ ] really know where
they're really yeah i swear to god bro i
never thought you would touch down with
keemstar you bought them on the show
yeah but you weren't on i was there
you oh on the new drummer show right
yeah yeah has there ever been an
interview that
he's done that you could have sat in on
but because of
90 90 of them well i was gonna say
because like obviously you come from a
certain you know background certain
politics involved you got certain
friends where you're just like i just
let i can't be a part of this yeah a lot
especially the [ __ ]
but then also like outside of you having
like maybe you having a little bit of
street [ __ ] might be weird but not that
but literally like i'll i only said okay
i'm gonna keep a g he
street guys he asked me to sit in those
with him right but for the most part i
only send the interviews that i like to
do so like if it's somebody i [ __ ] with
like kevin samuels i'm like i gotta i
gotta be there i just feel like it's
like having him co-host is a way of me
doing like a different interview with
like like especially g perico i
interviewed him like three years ago or
four years ago or whatever
he he said he wanted to do another one i
thought oh it'll be interesting to have
a d on this whole different interview i
already interviewed them so like you
know you guys have a relationship you
guys know each other he's going to ask
him different types of questions it's
it's just like a cool way to like make
something new again i think it's like
the last time you were like i just can't
be there for that like fake drake
fake training
but it's not like i was like hey dude
please pull up
he was like you're staying i was like no
i got better things i could do but once
in a while like when we did soak the
shocker he's like what the [ __ ] like i
want to call the opposite side
man that was my favorite rapper when i
was a little bro growing up hey you know
what's crazy is i was such a no limit
records fan i had the fake chain and
the note the masterpiece shoes bro i
felt accomplished
as an artist when still just dm me was
like yeah i [ __ ] with your [ __ ] what's
crazy is
when you go back and listen to silk he
was
technically one of the worst rappers
but he was look back then he was cool he
was that [ __ ] he was like the
superstar no limit very influential he
was doing the [ __ ]
like i never thought silk was a bad
rapper as a kid me neither but like i
grew up you know you get older and you
like become more like you know
well-versed in like
rhyme structures and people but i
wouldn't call them a bad rapper because
right there's [ __ ] right now that can
go off beat and people are like they're
a bad rapper no i just feel like he had
his own style at the time and it was
working for him he really wasn't rapping
you know what i mean but he did
something different that made him stand
out for sure for sure and it didn't age
well that's what he didn't age well
even though he hey man he was on some
hit records with maya come on
i like this [ __ ]
it's weird as [ __ ] charge to the game
man but i always liked like people who
are willing to just do something
completely different with their style
and like flow you know are you still i
mean i just saw you post your uh which
you actually listened to on apple it was
so bad it was like my number one artist
is like eight hours of total listening
to estg this year esg that's pretty bad
like eight hours total like that's not
that much if i did this in 2015 and they
were accurate and included soundcloud
and stuff i mean i guarantee my top
artist would have been like 80 hours of
[ __ ] listen to them you know like
i really don't listen to that much
[ __ ] music at this point like i
listen to
the [ __ ] that we talk about on the
podcast i listen to the artists that i'm
gonna interview on the podcast i i end
up finding random artists that i get
like really into but like
i mean at this point in my life i kind
of listen to music like a more like a
normal person because i'll have like oh
i found like oh i really like this push
icy tape this estg tape i'm going to
listen to it 40 times and then i'm going
to just you know listen to something
else and like
i don't know it's just i don't have that
like a r bug of like i gotta like find
out about every new rapper but
i have like a team who brings me i just
think it's a bandwidth thing right it's
like yo man i don't got that like i used
to it's time was beyond not writing two
dope boys trying to find whoever bro to
doughboy bro
[ __ ] with them but it's like now it's
like hey man if the shit's fire it's
gonna find me i like to drive i don't
listen to audiobooks bro get myself some
knowledge i just listen to podcasts yeah
i'm gonna check out
audio books like i'll watch like a three
hour podcast now that's i would just
ride around and be like okay does joe
rogan have someone interesting on this
week let me see what the [ __ ] they're
talking about i kind of like how like
the spotify [ __ ] is with academic [ __ ]
because it's like i didn't it took me a
minute to to see that if you turn your
phone you can watch the interview i was
like why isn't [ __ ] on youtube or
anything like that but like
oh you could you go if you have spotify
on your tv you could watch it there no
i'm talking like on my phone yeah like
returning and if you haven't screen it's
just audio really yeah and when you turn
it to the side it shows a [ __ ] video
yeah no idea yeah see it took me a
minute to figure that [ __ ] out but that
was dope
um all right when we're listening to
[ __ ] like that
like what what outside of your [ __ ] like
what's what podcast do you listen to
gilly and wallows man man i was worth
the game i don't know
i listened to like news podcasts for the
most part like political stuff like
people debating and arguing and stuff
like that honestly like i i do my job
and then i like get done with it and
it's like do i really want to listen to
like somebody i know
interview somebody i already interviewed
about a bunch of [ __ ] that i already
know you know it's just like that that
would be if i was like singularly
focused on being the best like hip-hop
commentator that i could be that i guess
is what i would do but i just like this
[ __ ] this holds me where do you
mostly get your news from adam i mean i
listen well i read the new york times
daily i read like i listened to a bunch
of different podcasts honestly i
listened to uh honestly with barry weiss
i'm really into sam harris
uh
there's a bunch of different people i
listen to and the twitter feed is just
you know that's really where i get like
a huge percentage of my news twitter is
where it's at um twitter is twitter but
yeah
twitter is where you get news and where
they don't censor the porn [ __ ] how
about i say that news and nudes news and
news you have to go into your settings
and allow yourself to view that though
because now we have like a plug talk
twitter right and i didn't change that
setting on it and i'm looking at girls
pages and realizing like you can't see i
don't even think you can look at my
girl's twitter
unless you've enabled sensitive my
twitter used to be so bad
any time i'd open it it would just be
like like a
butthole or some [ __ ] or a [ __ ] like
just i think that was twitter in general
because i don't be watching that [ __ ]
need to be there bro cause what it is is
if someone you're following likes a
picture of a pit a [ __ ] yeah oh it's
you there oh it's me no it'll pop up so
like you know you ain't even asking for
it and it's it's i'm like [ __ ] even
being so god gotta be adam there they've
made it a lot
less likely that you're gonna see porn
on twitter though i think at this point
they've made it so it's a lot it's like
really suppressed like okay a dude i
know did a porno scene that it was fake
but he basically like had this girl that
he that he was managing or working with
or whatever he had her like act like she
was sucking a bum's dick but really it
was like someone named a male porn star
guy that was like dressed up like a bum
which by the way if you're down let's do
this um and she uh she's sucking his
dick in this alley and i quote tweeted
it and actually and just acted like i
thought it was real and i got i was like
kind of trolling or whatever and i go to
look at it at the end of the day i was
doing podcasts i forgot go look at it
eight hours later
had like five likes
on the tweet this dude is so shadow band
that i quote tweeted them
with uh uh 800 something thousand
followers and i got five likes like
somehow this dude is in a very very
special category of
not
you know what's crazy is the shadow band
[ __ ] i just realized recently is like
real i used to think it was real they
didn't i used to think it was a thing
that like people who felt some type of
way about them not being as popping as
yeah because i know people who sometimes
it is though man it's cause i'm [ __ ]
shadow band cause i posted about the
vaccine
like shut the [ __ ] up bro you got 1200
followers
now you're getting like you know 30
likes instead of 37 likes and you're
convinced that the [ __ ] algorithm is
turned against i'll type in like you
know hollywood unlocked because you know
we do the radio show every day it don't
pop up it don't pop up oh academic
academics don't pop up but but then josh
was showing me that he types in aka in
academics box right up and i'm why is
no probably because he always goes to it
i don't know no i go to academics all
the time for news and [ __ ] some some
girls shouldn't pop up or how they want
lux i just did this hollywood actually
don't you've had girls on the patreon
where you had to type in every single
last letter to get their name and then i
will go to try to tag him in the photo
and it just erases the tag like
that [ __ ] you know what i [ __ ] don't
like
they keep demonetizing my [ __ ] show
for no [ __ ] he says [ __ ] this
week is monetized
so it was that then
he starts this podcast going off it's
the [ __ ] end of the day
yeah i think uh you really aren't
supposed to swear in the first minute i
was gonna say like you probably know
better than anyone what's because we've
had that happen to us
is it the first time in minutes well you
would probably know better i don't know
so much more she figured this out on the
first minute but then also i mean like
the blue jasmine and sharp thing just
got age restricted and demonetized even
though we edited out her saying the
[ __ ] f word towards him
the f-a-g-g-o-t word mm-hmm
that word is put to rest can't say no
more not but when me and him be kicking
it
no i call my best friend that oh
who's a straight male by the way
i've been friends with i mean you know
my best friend since childhood like
that's the term of endearment yeah uh
what's the dude's name who's on uh
dave andrew santino oh [ __ ] funny
cheeto i saw him uh i saw him open up
for joe rogan and he was he was saying
like i want to claim that word back no i
don't know
well he what he could probably get
he would say like in the sense of like i
want to be able to call my best friends
that word and not have people look at me
crazy
the only time i want to say it is when
i'm really mad
which i think is when people really
don't want you to use it yeah i'm like
yeah if somebody [ __ ] hit my car
that's what that would be what i would
want to scream you [ __ ]
yeah
these days
but nobody like the other day there was
a kid like an employee of somebody else
who was at
at the house filming something
and he's like he thinks he's like an
edgy funny like guy he thinks that he's
like you know a real like funny comedy
comedian type guy and he said it like
you [ __ ] like he said it to like
somebody else he was with and it was
like
everyone was like
you know that just sounds hella abrasive
now you know
when i hear that
my my thing is like if you're in mixed
company i feel like the way you should
talk completely yesterday i'm playing
poker and everybody kept trying to ask
me about the porn [ __ ] but there's like
a random girl sitting next to me that
you don't know i don't know her and i
don't want to [ __ ] have her hearing
me talk about this [ __ ] if it was just
the boys and you guys want to ask me
about it all right fine i'll talk about
it but i'm not like trying to have these
graphic conversations in front of
civilians that didn't sign up to have
that [ __ ] set in front of them you know
no not for sure i feel like the way i
talk to like my closest homies yeah
if you recorded those conversations oh
man we'd be done
yeah every i mean i like ju you should
see our group chat like that should
happen with john gruden he called roger
goodell the f word
even though
you know roger goodell's obviously but
you know he was talking to one of his
best friends
done took his statue down
he called me mayonnaise boy
mayonnaise boy
mayonnaise boy porn man i teared up
my man
oh he called me puma man oh look at nico
blitz getting free [ __ ] plug with the
[ __ ] who's the lunch table uh
nobody
nobody
eddie i want to ask you about this like
even you like because i feel like you're
where you are
um
obviously a lot of people know where no
jumper is
right so many interviews have happened
so all you need to do no you have
security i know you have security right
but like
la's hot right now
oh yes
it's [ __ ] crazy i just saw the video
of the lady with her [ __ ] with a
stroller
um
disgusting
uh i'm trying to remember
yeah his wife got [ __ ] dude
and then there's the other video that
came out last night of the dude who was
getting robbed and then he [ __ ] shot
the two guys oh yeah they're like
bleeding out in the [ __ ] street that
was tight that was nice
yeah i mean but like how do you like do
you move like with that [ __ ] in mind oh
yeah
i mean if somebody want to try to do
something to us you know i mean you can
shoot it out it'll be pointless robbing
him though
what do i got
my shoes are like 300
i guess that could be the best like like
obviously from your background and like
i'm you know i think that um
the edd [ __ ] getting infused into the
streets well for sure that was the worst
[ __ ] ever because
so much money was coming in i feel like
everybody who never had money got a
taste of what it was like to have you
know be able to live freely for a little
while and they don't want to go back to
that so [ __ ] is just going crazy but i
mean look i always tell everybody keep
your blammy they let out so many people
from the prison too bro there's so many
people that were supposed to be doing 20
years that are holiday times though
it's holiday times i've never got kids
but the other thing too is it's like
it's also
a little bit like in l.a
if you're like a law-abiding citizen
it's a lot harder to defend yourself and
if you're in phoenix arizona and you can
ha you know they make it very hard for
you to trap like yo like i think you
have to have
the bullets and the clip yes separated
and you have to have it registered and
you have to have your [ __ ] permit to
even do that [ __ ] that's why we're all
getting concealed carry permits this
year yeah we all yeah we go stop riding
dirty it just is crazy because it's like
you know i don't know man i feel like
you know i tell my wife i'm like i don't
wear your wedding ring when we go out
and see and that's and and that's where
it's [ __ ] up because like
women children old people should be off
the [ __ ] table if you catch a rapper
slipping you know what i'm saying they
drunk leaving the club eye whatever you
know i'm saying that's still wrong but
the fact that bro that
like you said a law-abiding a citizens
bro are are fearful to even go outside
and go eat and you can't do nah that
[ __ ] that's just that's bum [ __ ] and you
know the gun laws
it's all [ __ ] up and i think i think
like honestly
the
the
the laws have to be stricter on people
doing this [ __ ] right now that's that's
honestly how it's gonna stop that dude
who drove his car through the parade and
killed like five six seven people or
whatever and hit like 40 people or
whatever
i i heard that he had beaten the [ __ ]
out of his ex-girlfriend like a week
earlier less than a week and they let
him out on a thousand dollars bill yeah
well look prime example what's the uh
the story of your homeboy this guy was
just like had all these child
molestation charges and stuff they let
him out and he he kidnaps his rapper's
girlfriends and kills her it's just like
you know what i mean like like yeah the
justice system is [ __ ] up bro jerm is
like a rap brother that's like he's been
on tour suicide
boys from the uh from the valley yeah
i always used to see him over at trap's
house yeah and he was in a relationship
with this girl i feel bad about even
dragging this up but like he [ __ ] you
know she's coming home from work i think
she's a bartender
and the [ __ ] like a dude like follows
her home from a gas station or some [ __ ]
and [ __ ] takes her into his car and
like germ like sees it out the window
like as it's happening and tries to run
down and the guy drives off and
i mean it's a super [ __ ] up she died
yeah he killed her he killed her oh [ __ ]
and during and and then jerome also had
to deal with all these bum ass [ __ ]
on twitter and [ __ ] basically acting or
people acting like a [ __ ] yeah he's
snitching like like and he had just got
out of jail for a gun case too so he was
not able to like
have and his car was blocked in yeah
he's literally he really wouldn't have
been able to do [ __ ] no matter what he
did and then people are trying to like
act all high and mighty on him that's
what really pissed me off about it but
that's tough man it's a scary world we
live in do we do we feel like california
is too liberal
because i'm a liberal [ __ ] i
voted for bernie in the primaries you
know what i'm saying like
but i just keeps getting worse and the
republicans run on being tough on crime
as opposed to okay from the police
it's out it's over you get to talk about
defunding the police when crime seems
like it's going down like we don't need
these [ __ ] as soon as you have
a [ __ ] homicide spike like this
bro any any politician who says defund
the police you're not getting elected
period smarting the [ __ ] up because i
like being a liberal i like being a
democrat but i mean they're making it
really [ __ ] tough at a certain point
when you're letting everybody out when
everybody's scared when everybody's
scared for their family i mean be
[ __ ] serious this state will turn red
if they keep going the way they're going
yeah nah it's i don't know if it'll ever
turn red but nah
i don't i don't because when you look at
it if you look at california
the parts that are liberal that are
extremely extremely liberal are la and
san francisco and
the whole goddamn thing is red besides
that so it's not as
open and shut up also like when gavin
newsom got recalled like it's not like
the republicans had somebody who was
really like yeah
they had crazy people running
like like
like larry elder was saying some wild
[ __ ] yeah you know like it was what was
uh caitlyn jenner and it was like
like if they had maybe like um a
reasonable
yeah person well they're a bunch of
bozos for sure like i mean when you look
at the gop it's they're a bunch of
[ __ ] clowns for sure but i mean
as you saw with trump like when people
like are really convinced that there's
something to be scared of then they will
go with a clown who's pushing some
authoritative [ __ ] and authoritarian
[ __ ] and i just don't really i think
now that it seems like people really do
have something to be scared of
i mean they're they're gonna turn
against these [ __ ] politicians who
are enabling this
yeah i think uh
as as crazy as like we just got through
four years of
donald trump right who who normalized a
lot of [ __ ] up behavior in the country
and like you said the authoritarian [ __ ]
is
really some nazi [ __ ] that like if you
really look at like how hitler did his
[ __ ] and started very and you know i'm
not saying he's hitler but just the way
they
each of them started their political
careers very similar in the in the
antics that they were using
at the same time
i voted for joe biden and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on
like what is going on with this [ __ ]
guy like he's like the most they're so
unpopular right now and then meanwhile
they got kamala harris they can't run
her
because she's even more unpopular so
she's like the most unpopular vice
president of all time which i mean i'm
just gonna say the obvious he said he
was gonna give it to a woman
and then he had he boxed himself in he
boxed himself in and he basically like
had to choose a female person of color
so he picked the most
unpop like this is why like you don't
really want to be given opportunities
via affirmative action right
because then when it actually comes down
to it
like and you can't get anything done
because people don't like you it's like
well you probably didn't want to be in
this position in the first place right
yeah that's as
would either of you guys ever leave
california
never it's hard to imagine
i think the only place that would make
sense is if i had to go somewhere else
i'll go arizona i wouldn't say vegas
because there's no state tax and it's
it's just right there i feel like i have
to be around no you do [ __ ] you do at
least at this point in my life 100 no no
i mean that's why yeah i'm just thinking
like if there was ever a place i think
vegas would be the place i love hawaii
i i mean
i mean in terms of if you were to move
no jumper somewhere the only place
the only place that would make sense
that's close to l.a is vegas new york
and la and i guess vegas or miami or
australia and there's like very few like
like i don't think awesome
i love it i wouldn't go to austin at all
i lived in austin for a while and i
loved it but i was like 10 years arizona
bro i went to joe rogan's [ __ ] in austin
and that [ __ ] was uh very not what i
expected it to be really yeah like his
studio yeah who are you with i was a
fred
fred durst freddie gibbs oh yeah so we
went out there and uh
it was like in a you know you would
expect it to be like a big uh like a
[ __ ] compound yeah it's totally not
that it's like in it's like in between a
doctor's office and like an x-ray office
and that's hard in a business
uh just like a you know wow i never
would have thought that like you know on
[ __ ] hollywood way they're building
those new spots where the amazon [ __ ] is
yeah like by the airport
it's like looks like that well it's just
he just has a space and you would never
ever like know it's joe rogan that's
there because it's literally a doc like
an active doctor's office and like
another he's in between two just normal
businesses you should dox him right now
no i can't see where he's at but
but i mean he's got security and [ __ ]
but it's just it was just totally like
oh [ __ ] this is not what i think
barstool like looking at this [ __ ] was
like whoa that's like you went to their
[ __ ] no i'm talking about i've seen like
the drone footage that they put out uh
yesterday of like their compound and all
their shows and [ __ ] that's what i would
expect joe [ __ ] to be like
space because we copped like a crazy ass
building are you moving out of the wind
yeah
what's your rent couple weeks mm-hmm 4
500. ooh i know
but uh what ooh like a lot or like
uh but uh that
is kind of crazy because like
i don't know it just feels like we're
gonna be able to get so much staying in
the valley yeah yeah the valley's yeah
you know shout out to the valley man i
brought i love it yeah
shout out to
you but you're not in the valley like as
far as like where you you don't live
over here unlike you you sold out right
here i'm up here in this world yeah just
north of la world uh
adam real quick man before before we uh
end things because i know you got a busy
day what would be
you know for your from your perspective
some advice you would give content
creators that are are up and coming do
porn
i'm just kidding um
i guess my main thing
would just be to like find
what you have going for you that makes
you exciting or or that is exciting that
you're around you know like when i look
at like
because you know say cheese came up very
much like during no jumper already kind
of being pop well i don't know maybe
he's doing it longer than me right right
he's been around for a while but you
know when i look at his [ __ ] he like
really
found all these interesting people and
like interesting up and coming artists
like largely down south you know and
like just did hella content with them
and built a huge brand that gets
mentioned all the time as one of the
most relevant brands in rap music media
these days and i mean he did it by just
being like really authentically
into the [ __ ] that was going on in his
area and i mean it's like you're not
going to move to la and just be like all
of a sudden competing with vlad adam
right like kev et cetera et cetera all
these reasons
i'm not competing with y'all
you see he was sick he was like how did
a.d whiz is your homie how did you get
bootleg
how did he get him first so you you up
there with him i was just trying to
light the fire under your ass and get
you bro
you got all these famous friends and
then meanwhile you you you podcast with
you know
bro because the honestly for my show
artists don't [ __ ] work well why they
don't you are telling me that you
wouldn't want to sit down and have an
hour-long conversation with the game on
camera forever that's different that's a
personal friend that's why i say like
personal homework your show isn't
necessarily a like a
it's like more like showing this [ __ ]
yeah that's all i'm saying if you don't
have personality you can't take a joke
you're not gonna work on my show if i
were you as a broadcaster i would want
to also be having those conversations
and using your resources your
relationships just because i mean you're
in a unique position you have access to
people that a lot of people would kill
to be able to interview
personally i would do it i would say
like
you know
i haven't
i mean there's been a couple of times
where like i've gotten [ __ ] because i'm
like like the wish it right like whis
trust me you know will's one of my best
friends in the world you know what i'm
saying so like that was
a no-brainer um
but
i'm i'm like very careful about like
calling in like the homie favors
i'm like yo if it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen like that's how i feel like
our first episode was with fred
and fred durst no freddie gibbs
not a friend are you not a fan of fred
no i i like him yeah okay i don't know
i'm just looking around the second time
i do like fred dosa yeah shout out to
fred durst have you ever interviewed
twitter's no that'd be epic is he racist
he looks like a goat now significant
other man you know by the way
side note music that didn't age well
limp [ __ ] biscuits
i would have told you that in like they
were my favorite band in 97
and i would have told you that in 98.
bro now i disagree
because now it sounds great to me one of
the listeners the only song that sounds
great is the [ __ ] in together now
that primo produced because all that
other [ __ ] i'm like yo
nookie was so terrible
this guy he's trying to rewrite history
corn aged corn aged well
i still [ __ ] with corn like that like
you know there was like corn kid rock
and limp biscuit were like the big three
[ __ ] rock were they the kid rock's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah for sure really oh
kid rock is like the worst i know he's
like republican now but no no he's like
disrespectful though he don't like us
really
he's got a he's got a mixed child so
people forget or people don't drummer's
black that before
before kid rock was like 1998 kid rock
kid rock was like an aspiring rapper for
years and years like a regular ass yeah
like a song with too short he was signed
before he did that
yeah and then he kind of blew up as this
like party animal dude you know kid rock
is 100 like maggot the [ __ ] out though
yeah yeah yeah he's there's like a whole
are you hip to the maga rap it's like a
whole dark not really i don't think bruh
it's bad really there is this entire
world
because you know i'm cool with like a
lot of white rappers jelly rolls my boy
ritz yeah you know yellow these are my
my people right shout out jelly roll
there is a [ __ ] underbelly of hip hop
and there's like one dude who's black
who's a mega rapper i forget his name
but there are like three or four dudes
who are when they drop their number one
on itunes wow really i didn't know that
uh
[Music]
man it's crazy he's familiar but he
don't know their names you don't want to
give them love no i don't want to give
them love i know one of their names
because they're beefing with my boy
caskey but there's like a there's a guy
named burden
um i had ritz on here like a couple
weeks ago and i just shot i shot on all
those guys i'm like yo the [ __ ] like
and it's crazy because that world like
when we think of like white rappers like
a lot of a lot you know you there's a
lot of those kids that the only rapper
that they [ __ ] with is yellow wolf i'm
like oh i wonder what i wonder what what
it could be about yellow wolf and eminem
that you like so much you know what i'm
saying
everything else you listen to is
credence and [ __ ] tim mcgraw and
yeah that's why i used to feel when
eminem came out and on the rock radio
station in my town they started playing
eminem and i'm like so you guys have
ignored every rap song ever and it's not
like he's doing like alternative yeah
and like for some reason this guy who's
basically making rap music it's a little
weird but it's it's rap music and like
this is okay with you like this is the
most racist thing this is the most
incredible evidence of your radio
station not really being about
type of music
it's about who what color is that
because it'd be the alternative
alternative stations would start playing
eminem rap songs and it'd be like like
what yeah it's just because he's white
yeah you know who who who recently uh
something similar happened with that
you're a rock fan having to hear eminem
my name is on the radio you'd probably
be so mad their music uh transcended the
rock radio was uh run the jewels they
worked their record but that makes more
sense their music is very alter like
and these days the line is really kind
of blurred don't you think we're like
also
let me be the person to tell you guys
radio is [ __ ] uh again it's the
bullet cap says that
streets is a myth
streets is it okay ah that's right troy
i'm gonna say all right troy
all right troy yeah
the radio [ __ ] is like um
if you want to go number one on bill
gotta do it you need radio
but if you want to be successful or
you're an up-and-coming artist it should
be the very last thing you're worried
about
[ __ ] actually think if i played
like their song at 11 o'clock at night
it's gonna change their life there's
also dudes with 200 followers that think
if i interview them that they're going
to be famous
and it's just it's not entitlement man
you're going to get the record for the
the least viewed no jumper interview in
history and that's probably not what you
want
did you ever have a um
you i saw you just have violent j on
you've had icp on a couple of times
right
did you ever have a
[ __ ]
era of of life coming up when psychopath
records was oh yeah in your rotation you
want to hear an embarrassing story to
end this because we kind of go yeah yeah
i'm in eighth grade and um it was
halloween and i genuinely liked icp at
this time of my life this is a great
malinko era yes and me and a couple of
my friends wore our icp paint to school
and there was a dude that i had beef
with because
we were friends when we were in seventh
grade now i'm in eighth grade and i had
realized that he had stolen some jinkos
from my house she goes he stole some
shopkins pants ever from my house so
me and him had to fight in the woods
after school so i'm fighting this dude
who's way smaller than me but props to
him he did choose to throw hands and uh
i a bunch of the paint had kind of been
rubbed off my face at this point as a
result of us fighting and my mom is
driving home from work and she sees
me on the side of the road like off like
in the cut a little bit but she sees me
for some reason it was really weird she
sees me and she pulls up and she gets to
see her 14 year old son
with his insane clown paint dripping off
his face beating up a kid in the woods
over jinkos
and i would say that that probably feels
like one of the low points of my life
nothing like
are you down with hash brown town
nothing like how [ __ ] up my cousin was
a jinko wearing kid and the bottom of
his jeans oh they were so just so ripped
up that was the style for a while just
destroyed but either that or you would
cuff them like eight times or you would
cuff the [ __ ] out big ass jeans or
something yeah bro
the [ __ ] pockets were the size of
this tv that's crazy though because you
can fit a two liter of fago they were
popping out of l.a but like i guess
probably not in compton so much dude
jingles were a wave it was like the
white trash [ __ ]
jinko pants a two liter amount i didn't
know you could spend sixty dollars on a
pair of pants until jingles
i mean i was like they had like they had
like the stitch [ __ ] on the pockets yeah
you have like an elephant like a
graffiti style elephant
embroidered on the pocket
they probably missed so much money man
they keep trying to sell that company
every couple of years they change his
hands and they try to bring it back and
give a [ __ ] well listen appreciate you
pulling up uh
when you're putting out music bro uh
february
what's he putting out
i'm shooting some videos saturday
all right we're stacking up everything
only fans videos
are is your only fans coming soon no man
you're in a relationship yeah
but actually if it's how i mean not no
if his album don't sell then he might be
on only fence so everybody else oh
please don't listen to it buy my [ __ ]
i'm about to
join the porn man we're out with this
[ __ ] proud of this guy for not being at
every night club that trey songz is at
yo trey can i get another bottle
no hey man we're in vegas right now we
had cosmo tonight with trey song i'm
just playing you saw that the
accusations are just
what happened he got accused of sexual
assault like last weekend in vegas at
the cosmo the homie the homie didn't do
it man homie free trade songs
free tray there it is